[Music]
[Applause]
what year is it regardless of whether
you're under house arrest or under
quarantine from a worldwide pandemic
social isolation is not going to be easy
if you're not careful it can be as
deadly as smoking 15 cigarettes a day so
we've put together some expert advice to
help you get through it after all we
know you have the time to watch this
video here's how to survive social
isolation social isolation may be new to
you but people survive long periods of
it all the time take astronauts for
example the longest stretch ever spent
in space by one astronaut was 438 days
by russian astronaut Valeri polikov one
thing he says helped him survive the
isolation was the strict schedule of
maintaining the spacecraft it helped to
keep his mind occupied and his days
structured but you don't have a
spacecraft to maintain so what should
you be doing to survive should you
maintain your regular schedule how good
video chats affect your chances of
surviving and why could going crazy
during this isolation be a good thing
luckily for you we've put together a
definitive list of six tips from experts
and survivors to answer all your
questions number one limit your screen
time it might be tempting to fill your
lonely days by consuming all the endless
online content that's available to you
but staring at a screen all day every
day can be very bad for you not only can
it lead to a sedentary lifestyle it can
also cause vision issues headaches and
chronic neck and back pain
on top of that the blue light from
digital devices suppresses the sleep
promoting hormone melatonin which could
cause trouble sleeping number two get
some sunlight speaking of sleeping
remember to open your curtains and let
the Sun Shine in this can help you
maintain your sleep-wake schedule which
can be disrupted when people are
isolated in complete darkness messing up
this schedule known as your circadian
rhythm can also lead to depression and
fatigue number three take a creative
journey you have all the time in the
world so why not get a little creative
with it like something paint something
or finish that rock opera you've always
dreamed of oh let go of the need to do
something important all the time and
just let your mind wander it can do
wonders for your relaxation rejuvenation
and personal growth
number four limit your news updates if
you're isolated for something like a
quarantine you should try to limit the
amount of time you spend checking the
news only check reputable sources and
select one or two times each day when
you check them checking too often can
cause unnecessary stress and make the
time seem to pass more slowly
number 5 reach out to support others in
isolation socially isolated doesn't have
to mean socially disconnected in a lot
of these situations you'll still have
access to your phone and internet
communications so why not use them
research shows that those with weaker
social relationships are 50% more likely
to die over a given period of time than
those with stronger relationships in
other words having social connections is
very important for our well-being
positive social support can help us
adjust to challenges and cope with
stress reaching out to offer support to
others is a good way to feel less alone
and it helps you to control your own
anxiety by giving you a sense of purpose
number six it's okay if isolation drives
you a little crazy social isolation may
not always feel comfortable it could
make you cry laugh yell and dwell on
things that your mind usually wouldn't
have time for but that might not be a
bad thing let this be an opportunity to
push your boundaries of awareness of
time of yourself and of your
relationships you may be able to leave
this social isolation with a greater
appreciation for all things in your life
that you used to take for granted so
there you have it now you know how to
make it through this tough time with it
at least a little bit of your sanity
intact and hey why not share these tips
with your friends because above all else
it's important to stay connected with
others during a challenge like this now
that you've survived social isolation
it's time to return to the real world if
everyone else was also living in social
isolation that whole time the real world
might look a lot different than you
remember but whether the economy is in
shambles or the world has run out of
toilet paper we'll have a video to help
you survive whatever awaits you
[Music]